ces images ont fait et font toujours le
tour de la planète
jeff keay 35e président des états unis
avec sa femme jackie qui débarque à
dallas et qui s'en vont dans cette
voiture parcourant les rues de la ville
texane une promenade fatal pour le
président frappé en pleine tête par une
deuxième balle
kennedy sera déclaré mort peu de temps
après
longeant les américains dont la
consternation la plus totale selon l'anc
est l'assassin du président s'appelle
lee harvey oswald qui aurait tiré depuis
une fenêtre de la bibliothèque située
sur le chemin de l'apparaître
présidentielle mais il ne livrera jamais
ses secrets lui même abattu deux jours
après son arrestation par jack ruby
la grande majorité du dossier d enquête
plus de 30 mille documents ont déjà été
rendus publics mais il en restait trois
mille autres gardé secret c'est le film
d'oliver stone gfk qui a fait bouger les
choses
forçant l'adoption d'une nouvelle loi
pour dévoiler le dossier dans lequel 25
ans plus tard soit aujourd'hui le 26
octobre 2017
mais après en avoir promis la
publication totale donald trump a décidé
de retenir trois cents documents pour
des raisons de sécurité nationale
donnant ainsi des munitions aux
conspirationnistes qui vont encore s'en
donner à coeur joie aux wald était-il
vraiment le seul tireur et pourquoi
s'est il rendu quelques semaines plus
tôt au mexique dans les ambassades russe
et cubaine les soviétiques et est il
derrière ce meurtre
et cet homme at il ouvert son parapluie
pour donner un signal au moment où
kennedy arrive dans sa limousine et si
c'était lyndon johnson
le vice-président de kennedy qui avait
fomenté ce coup d'état
notre histoire mais c est la vraie
histoire selon cet auteur d'un livre sur
l'assassinât de kennedy c'est pourquoi
la cia et qui savait certaines choses se
reçoit lé de plusieurs semaines avant
l'attentât n'a rien dit ou rien fait il
faudra du temps pour que les experts
révèlent ce que cachent les 2800
documents nouvellement publiées quant
aux 300 dossiers restés secrets
le président trump a donné six mois au
fbi et à la cia et pour qui les rendent
disponibles avec le moins de caviardage
possible
en attendant 60% des américains croient
toujours un complot mais une seule
certitude demeure le président kennedy a
bel et bien été assassiné le 22 novembre
1963 à dallas ici il frédéric arnould
radio canada montréal